hi thank you for uh
to the organizers for
uh well uh
this will mostly be a survey stock uh
just because I'm yes
because I assume that
so that it's more accessible to more
people
if anyone wants details of any of the
proofs I'll be happy to talk about it
okay
before yeah
so as complexity theorists everyone
wants to attack this question and just
like various branches of complexity
Theory would attach this question in
different ways like
something I've learned during this uh
Workshop that true complexity would like
to I would attack this you uh in by
asking the MP versus go NP question or
meta complexity would ask whether the
MCS create problem is NP hard or in
bounded arithmetic what I understand
please don't get about this whether like
whether the P not equal to NP statement
is consistent in some Theory
similarly in algebraic circuit
complexity we want to attack the P
versus NP question by asking the VP
versus vnp question and in particular
it's a natural stepping stone because if
you believe that P is not equal to NP
then under the
undergrh we also believe that when it it
has to be that VP is not equal to vnp
and is therefore a much simpler question
and
we that that's the central goal of
algebraic circuit complexity
so what what are these classes that I
spoke about vpvmp
so the basic uh
computational model
in uh in this field is the algebraic
circuit which is uh uh yeah it's been
defined before but I'll just repeat the
definition uh it's a directed basically
graph in which the leaves are labeled by
variables or some field constant
and the internal nodes are labeled by uh
addition or multiplication Gates and
therefore naturally any node in this
graph computes a polynomial and the
polynomial computed at the root is said
to be the polynomial computed by the
circle
so in particular this circuit computes
this point
so and the objects of study is in this
field are polynomials Over N variables
in general of degree D and uh
as in most complexity Theory
um fields we want to give lower Bonds on
the size of the smallest
circuit Computing some explicit
polynomials okay so it is again as usual
it is easy to say that most polynomials
require really large size circuits this
comes just by counting arguments
and what we want to show is that what we
want to show is that there exists an
explicit polynomial I won't Define what
that means but essentially it's like an
explicit polynomial is a polynomial
Indian
such that it cannot be computed by
circuits of poly and D size so polyandy
side circuit polynomial is computable
bipoliant surface is what we think we
want to separate
and what is known uh quite a bit uh for
I mean in this talk I'll just
um there are many restricted classes as
was mentioned in my stock but for now
I'll just talk about constant depth
circuits
and recently in the Breakthrough result
it was shown that the first Super
polynomial lower bounds were shown
against uh constant depth circuits
and in particular for depth 3 the lower
bound is Into The Omega Ruby
although constant depth circuit lower
bonds are known in the Boolean setting
what makes this really exciting in the
algebraic setting is that we actually
know very good depth reduction results
in the algebraic setting which is not
known in the Boolean set
in particular we know that
a policy circuit can be reduced to a
depth
foreign
by blowing up the size to s to the to T
and also in fact it can be reduced to
product depth one so the same as deb3 uh
some power some product some
circuits also uh by boarding up the
sides to s to the root D and therefore
you see that this at least at product
depth 1 the lower bound is packed
oh yeah
however in the general setting if that's
for arbitrary depth the best lower bound
continues to be not that great it it's
just n log D due to a very old result of
power and stuff
um yeah so
so we know
the best possible thing for constant
depth circuits
general setting uh it's uh not that good
so there are other restricted models
that we would like to study in this talk
I will focus so we've already seen
vpnbnp but we'll talk about two other
models which one of which is formulas so
formulas are similar to circuits except
that the underlying graph is only
allowed to be a tree instead of a dag
and polynomials which can be computed by
polycized formulas is uh said to be the
class BF
and
it turns out that there's another very
natural class called vbp which lies in
between VF and VP in
and apart from the VP versus vnp
question I mean extremely important
question in algebraic circuit complexity
is like the whether each of these
inclusions attacked
foreign
[Music]
you know smaller and smaller depth and
uh
yeah so so
the result I mentioned is showed that bf
uh
we have you know constant
constant depth formulas are separate
from bbp because the hard polynomial
turned out was actually in bbp that was
what LST had shown and in general they
actually show a hierarchy of hierarchy
in the constant depth regime so for any
constant Delta they show that there is a
separation between these two classes
now what what can we say outside uh you
know we have the it turned out that the
best thing you can so for example
between bbp and VP is just a
n poly login versus n Square separation
that's the best thing you can say about
here and between VP and the best lower
bound against VP is just power stressing
[Music]
um
okay
so in yeah as the title slide says the
focus of this talk is going to be on a
restricted class a restricted setting
called the not which is the
non-commutative okay what is the
non-community
here uh the multiplication Gates they
um they respect order okay so
non-commutative circuits they are
essentially the same as uh commutative
circuits except that
multiplication gets now uh respective
and the question is can we do something
better in this setting
as compared to the
uh how good it is making
and
so let's just re-look at the things that
we mentioned
uh the depth reduction statement is the
same
but the separation between you know
formulas and bbp it for uh it because it
works for root log D instead of log log
D so in the commutative setting they
could show a separation for Delta for uh
yeah for depth
up to log log D whereas here they have
root log d
and
[Music]
um
also they show that if you consider
homogeneous formulas and avps then uh
there's a separation
this is all in the non-committed
and most remarkable which is where this
thing started this Nissan in 1991 which
is also the result that Edo had
mentioned in the morning uh the using
his lower Bond he could show that
um
that there is a polynomial in PP which
is not contained in this class so in the
commutative world the lower bound is I
mean the separation is like n log Square
n versus n Square whereas here it's an
exponential separation so there's
something in VP which requires
exponential sized abuse
and
also in this setting we have very good
hardness amplification results which are
again not known in the community
so it's same so in the in the
non-commutative setting it we we seem to
have a lot of
because of the because of the extra
structure that we have we can exploit
them actually and which is why I think
this is like a very exciting domain
because
it at least to me it feels like you know
we
we should be able to solve a lot of the
important problems at least in this set
so
so now that we know that Nissan has
already proved the suppression between
these two uh for the rest of the talk I
would like to focus on like what is
happening in VP versus BNP in the
non-commutated setting and also between
vvp and bf what what is the status
so what happened
of course yeah
so what is the status of BP versus VMP
so unfortunately uh
the best lower bound that we know
against non-commutative circuits
continues to be the same thing that we
know for communities which is okay
so what we asked is can we at least do
better when if we assume that the
circuits are homogeneous okay
um
and yeah recently we could show that we
could improve this lower bound from n
log D to ND okay so this is and it's
actually certain activities about this
and beyond that it becomes n log B log
log n by
log b or something but essentially it
and again uh this polynomial actually
has a better upper bound if we don't
have the homogeneity restriction
so this is again giving a very slight
separation but
I mean homogeneous and non-homogeneous
circuits in the normal
so I will just give us
um yeah slide over proof overview of
this and which will also help me tell
you about the usual template for proving
algebraic circuit logo so in general
what you what we do is we Define a
measure
such that for the so
so so that if a polynomial is being
computed by a size s instance of some
model then the measure is small so small
in terms of NDS
and for the given polynomial it's large
right and that will that allows us to
give a lower bound on S
and so what is the measure that we use
so suppose f is a homogeneous
non-commutative polynomial of degree D
then
we Define f i to be polynomials so note
that because it is non-commutative there
is this additional notion of position
right so uh
because the order is important so what
we do is that we say for a given uh
non-commutative polynomial uh f f i is
the polynomial you get by setting the
variables in position I and I plus 1
uh sorry to keep skip those and set
everything else too okay
and then we look at the uh rank of the
space generated so for example if you
had this F was the sum of two monomials
then so which is X1 through x d plus x d
2 x 1 then F of 1 is going to be X1 plus
X2 plus sorry x 1 x 2 plus x d x d plus
1 okay so we are we are not focusing on
the variable number it's the position
number that
minus
as you can see the measure is quite
simple and in fact you can't get a the
highest this measure can be is like B
okay and the um
then Lemma is that we say that this
measure is at most s if it is being
compute if there is a polynomial which
is being computed by a
homogeneous
okay so once we have that Lemma what we
do is that so how do we so as I said the
highest this measure can be is B but we
managed to get an ND lower Bond but
where we do that is by using this uh
trick of power instruction where they
say that if f is being computed by a
circuit of size s
you can compute all that partial
derivatives simultaneously without
blowing up the size just the constant
Factor
so we uh we have to prove a homogeneous
version of that uh which which is
it doesn't take yeah it's a little bit
of work but it's not very difficult we
managed to do that and again because
um
because we are working in the
non-commutative setting partial
derivatives is with respect to the first
position but uh our thing works even in
the general homogeneous
you can you can show that if this uh if
a polynomial is computed by a
homogeneous Circuit of size s then the
usual partial derivatives can be
computed with only a 5S
involved
okay and once you have that you'll note
that our previous summer didn't require
on continues to work if you assume that
there are multiple outputs doesn't need
to be single out
and you saw that for our Hardball number
it is actually
getting getting the lower amount
this is our this is the proof overview
so now I will yeah I will try to see uh
I had mentioned that there is this
hardness amplification result known in
this setting right so does our lower
bound says you know give something
better than what we say using this thing
it turns out that it we can't get
anything which is really better why
because
so
um
what cilm says is that if you have an N
to the Omega by 2 plus Epsilon lower
Bound for you know some polynomial Over
N variables of degree B
then you can improve the lower Bound by
uh
increase by increasing the degree
reducing the number so you get an
improved lower Bound for another
polynomial which has now fewer uh
fewer number of variables and degree
which is much better okay
but so now and now how much the
Improvement you get it starts degrading
as the degree
as this degree becomes larger and larger
so as if B is constant for example which
is the person I had written this
improved lower bound is exponential if D
is poly in N then this is just poly in N
but either way for so what is the lower
bond that we have it is ND right so for
CLM to start peaking in we need degree
to be n to the Epsilon
and for that the improved lower bound
that you get is not it it's worse than
ND
so it doesn't really make sense
which which brings me to like questions
which would be very interesting is that
uh and can possibly like solve the VP
versus the NP question in the
non-communitive setting is that can be
so uh
can we show a lower Bond similar like
and it can't be ND but basically can we
show super linear lower bounds for uh
when the degree is sub polynomial in
okay you know like not n to the Epsilon
but some something smaller than that in
that setting can we show super linear
load forms if if we can then cilm will
start kicking in and we start getting
like much better lower pumps then
and secondly uh
can we have hardness amplification
statements which work better when B is
large
then again a statement that we have
would start giving much better loads
so in the VP versus the NP question I
think these are like
very
interesting questions which have thought
about a little but yeah
it was very interesting to eat any of
either of these two
uh okay and
that's all I want to say about the VP
versus dnp in non-communicated setting
and now I will spend like a couple of
slides on the VF versus VPP question in
the non-complete
this Edo had mentioned this in the in
this talk but let's uh as you mentioned
I mean this is a remarkable uh
easy to prove result and I'll just
mention it again so
foreign that if you have uh if you have
a polynomial of degree D and you
consider this Matrix so what is the
Matrix
um you so for any I you can write all
possible monomials you can
degree up to I and all monomials of
degree D minus I in the column and what
is so for the entry in the M1 M2 uh
foreign
times M2 in F okay and he showed that uh
for
any I in between 1 and D the number of
vertices in the ith layer of the
smallest ABP Computing f is going to be
exactly equal to the rank of this Matrix
which is which makes it like on yeah I
mean we don't really get to see exact
characterizations of uh
sizes in from complexities which makes
this
really nice result
and therefore gives like tight sides
bounce on uh
for any polynomial and so using this you
get an exponential lower bound
for against abps and hence formulas
for a polynomial which is in yeah so
this is actually in VP non-commutative
and this gives you a separation
so in some sense we already have formula
lower bounds in the non-communicative
setting except that
this works for abps and which makes the
question of the the X versus DBP in the
non-committed setting extremely
interesting
and what I mean yeah till very recently
actually there had been hardly any
progress towards this question but in
the last two three years there has been
a lot of perfect
so
so uh as I had mentioned so in the
non-commutative setting like this year
it was shown that you could depth reduce
to log depth without increasing the size
uh find more than polynomial factors
and it turned out that uh in in the
paper uh nutan srikant and Sebastian
sort that up to root log D I mean
there's an order here root log B you can
show a separation okay so you you know
how to depth reduce up to log B and you
know how to separate from log D onwards
so the question obviously is can this
Gap be closed okay
and uh so beyond log B yeah you you
would expect that you can't uh you would
expect that the
blow up starts becoming super polynomial
but like what you know like how how do
these two interact it's very interesting
this is one way and the other thing is
um in the same in the same paper they
show that uh in the homogeneous setting
formulas and Mbps are separate right
the point is that this lower bound is
not tight so this lower bound is n to
the log log n for a degree n polynomial
actually the
the iterative matrix multiplication of
degree n and the point is that if it had
been typed then you would have separated
not only VF and vvp in the
non-communitative setting but also in
the general setting if their proof would
have yeah
this uh
yeah a formula is already a log t log
depth right looking for those details so
what else is
okay but uh but this was already
I thought it's over there but it wasn't
then
so and if this would have been tight so
either
if it had been into the login
for the same polynomial
okay and the point is that this proof
Works in a slightly more General
what do I mean by unordered settings so
in the non what is the last uh so uh
non-commutative setting as I mentioned
the position matters right so in some
sense you can think of variables
appearing in position I to belong to a
bucket I okay and their proof actually
doesn't so this group this one moves
away but this one does not use the fact
that in the non-commutative setting the
buckets actually come in an ordered
fashion okay so the point is that can be
used the additional fact that it is
ordered to actually improve this
is
[Music]
because it is homogeneous
because the formula is homonymous you
also have that the
or
reflecting the order
but this works as long as you assume
that uh
things appear like things from a bucket
appears only once it doesn't use the
fact that it is
and this was some problem this ordering
theme is why
why I had also tried to
attack this question and I could show a
separation between the Indian and
different sort of a structured formula
in which uh you the formula is assumed
to respect the order but
so you have buckets I won't Define what
this is it's just it's a made-up sort of
but
essentially the idea was that in the
non-commutative setting
if you assume that the polynomial is uh
ordered then and you additionally assume
that the formula is ordered then can you
show a separation which is what I could
do except that again
the same thing so
it turns out that if
if you had a
super polynomial separation between
homogeneous formulas and abdps for a
polynomial that has degree login then
you would be done okay except but their
proof Works only for degree n so in the
similar way for in this setting
the
the degree is login but the number of
buckets in some sense is n and if the
number of buckets was login then again
it would have separated VF and bbp in
the non-communitive setting so it seems
like we yeah I don't know I mean ever
since this paper had come out the Hope
was that you know
assuming this additional ordered setting
maybe we will be able to separate VF and
UTP and I still hope that we we should
be able to do it soon
okay
let's and because we are in a proof
complexity and meta complexity program I
would like to give two additional open
threads which I haven't really thought
about so don't ask me too much about it
but if I mean they seem very interesting
and
one is that you could ask are there
peanuts or proofs for vpnc and
because of cilm even proving if BP
natural to suggest for these uh
for bits of size which are Super
polynomial super linear for low degree
they all that also becomes interesting
and yeah I'm not there any connections
between two complexity lower bonds and
you know lower Bonds in the
non-communications we know that there
are in the community testable
I mean the only one I know of is This
non-communitive IPS which uh
which doesn't lead to anything because
we already know formula lower bounds
here but you know especially this yeah
but
are there anymore
the formula into slides before so I mean
if it's over there and also ordered and
non-community uh
seems to me the same or ordered and
non-committed if it's ordered
yes it is so the
is
just for that is not enough but the
hopeful that we can make it
um
it's like it makes sense only in the
non-consuming
and you can you can have it put it on
that and say I want the syntaxify to
order like the products so that they
will respect some order but the
polynomial is non-commutative
is community teacher
it's just a syntactic
constraints
in the formula you you need it to be so
the polynomial
um which I don't think I'm understanding
so you're saying that if the polynomial
is commutative and and your
foreign
then you know that if your buckets was
uh just what are the variables appearing
in
in position
and in that in in the noise
but I just I wanted it to
um like generalize this
you are allowed to Define buckets
and suppose your polynomial is such that
it respects the ordering of the buckets
the
non-committed formula Now does not have
I mean by why in the consultation it
need not be respected there might be
answerless
right so this that whatever
defined that was where formulas was
[Music]
of that type which is essentially the
same proof as like why you can make it
homogeneous when the degree is not
foreign
[Applause]